there was a great video i saw this one
girl super smart
posts a tick tock where instead of just
focusing on her
you know super high after seven bong
hits kind of
weird subjectivist pseudo-philosophy she
uses
facts and logic to explain how there is
a reality to the universe and by the way
the sub stratum of that reality the the
the
essence that keeps the being that keeps
the whole thing going that undergirds
all of it
is god who exists have y'all ever heard
of the theory of general relativity it's
what einstein is famous for
in his calculations he started to
realize that the universe was not
eternal
it had a beginning now this leads us to
the law of causality
everything that came to be needs a cause
so einstein
clearly knew that if the universe had a
beginning
it needed a cause let's go to the big
bang theory there was no space
no time and no matter before the big
bang
the universe emerged out of nothingness
what does that mean since it's
impossible for
the universe to be able to create itself
because
it didn't exist in order to be able to
create itself
nature and the universe itself was just
a big effect
that was caused by what are we left with
an extremely powerful
extremely intelligent precise given the
precision that our universe was created
with
personal entity that is capable of
existing outside of time space and
matter
that can't be nothing but god do i need
to sign up for tick tock now
i didn't i thought tick tock was just a
bunch of crazy people
spouting off and then a bunch of other
people jiggling around and i figured
this is not and and also xi jinping
stealing all of our information
so i assume there's no reason for me to
be on tiktok
but if i can go on tick-tock and just
hear popular apologetics and
very strong and common sense arguments
for the existence of god maybe i gotta
sign up and get an account
do you see the difference between what
this gal is saying on tiktok and
say what demi lovato is saying in her
social media post
they're both giving their visions of the
universe right they're both
describing i guess even their identity
or where they find themselves in the
universe
but with demi lovato's you can't make an
argument
for or against it because she's just
saying it's all just about my personal
feeling my personal private revelation
that i had of who i am but i don't even
know who i am yet even though i know who
i am but i don't know who i'm going to
be
but i am who i'm going to be and
therefore you just have to believe me
and if you don't you know you're kind of
a meanie and you'll hear more from my
friend alok or whatever
this gal is coming out and saying hey
you have faculties of reason there is
an observable reality that we can
perceive and then we can use our reason
to work that out have conceptions right
and follow
arguments to their logical conclusion
and because this world
is is caused because we're all sort of
caused beings and contingent beings
even then you've got to trace that all
the way back
to god to an unmoved mover to an
uncaused cause that's not just a hey man
wouldn't it be weird if it were like
this that's a that's a logical
argument if we are going to have a
society that is living in reality
we got to base it on that you can't it's
not
possible to be living in reality if you
base it on the demi lovato thing
because demi lo it's not even just that
she's wrong it's that she doesn't accept
reality that reality exists at all but
unfortunately
the demi lovato theory of the world is
is much more fashionable at the moment
than that girl's theory of the world
also also thomas aquinas
theory of the world that she's she's
reciting the trans ideology is more
popular at the moment
hey there are you living in the demi
lovato fantasy land you probably are if
you have not run that bell if you have
not subscribed
because you all you're doing is swimming
in this morass of delusion and fantasy
but what you got to do is live in this
reality based community okay ring that
bell
like subscribe i'll see you next time
[Music]